Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to simulate these absolutely
beautiful thin film structures.
You see, computer graphics researchers have
been writing physics simulation programs for
decades now, and the pace of progress in this
research area is absolutely stunning.
Here are three examples of where we are at
the moment.
One, this work was able to create a breathtaking
honey coiling simulation.
I find it absolutely amazing that through
the power of computer graphics research, all
this was possible four years ago.
And the realistic simulation works just kept
coming in.
This work appeared just one year ago and could
simulate not only a piece of viscous fluid,
but, also deal with glugging and coalescing
bubbles.
And three, this particular one is blazing
fast.
So much so that it can simulate this dam break
scene in about 5 frames per second, not seconds
per frame, while it can run this water drop
scene with about about 7 frames per second.
Remember, this simulates quantities like the
velocity, pressure, and more for several million
particles this quickly.
Very impressive.
So, are we done here?
Is there anything else left to be done in
fluid simulation research?
Well, hold on to your papers, and check this
out.
This new paper can simulate thin-film phenomena.
What does that mean?
Four things.
First, here is a beautiful oscillating soap
bubble.
Yes, its color varies as a function of the
evolving film thickness.
But that’s not all.
Let’s poke it, and then…did you see that?
It can even simulate it bursting into tiny,
sparkly droplets.
Phew.
One more time.
Loving it.
Second, it can simulate one of my favorites,
the Rayleigh-Taylor instability.
The upper half of the thin film has a larger
density, while the lower half carries a larger
volume.
Essentially, this is the phenomenon when two
fluids of different densities meet.
And what is the result?
Turbulence.
First, the interface between the two is well
defined, but over time, it slowly disintegrates
into this beautiful swirly pattern.
Oh yeah…oh yeah!
Look!
And it just keeps on going and going.
Third, ah yes, the catenoid experiment.
What is that?
This is a surface tension-driven deformation
experiment, where the film is trying to shrink
as we move the two rims away from each other,
forming this catenoid surface.
Of course, we won’t stop there, what happens
when we keep moving them away?
What do you do think?
Please stop the video and let me know in the
comments below.
I’ll wait.
A little.
Thank you!
Now then, the membrane keeps shrinking, until…yes,
it finally collapses into a small droplet.
The authors also went the extra mile and did
the most difficult thing for any physics simulation
paper…comparing the results to reality.
So, is this just good enough to fool the untrained
human eye, or is this the real deal?
Well, look at this, this is an actual photograph
of the catenoid experiment.
And this is the simulation.
Dear Fellow Scholars, that is a clean simulation
right there.
And, fourth, a thin film within a square subjected
to a gravitational pull that is changing over
time.
And the result is more swirly patterns.
So how quickly can we perform all this?
Disregard the FPS, this is the inverse of
the time step size, and is mainly information
for fellow researchers.
For now, gaze upon the time per frame column,
and, my goodness.
This is blazing fast too!
It takes less than a second per frame for
the catenoid experiment, this is one of the
cheaper ones.
And all this on a laptop!
Wow!
Now, the most expensive experiment in this
paper was the Rayleigh-Taylor instability,
this took about 13 seconds per frame.
This is not bad at all, we can get a proper
simulation of this quality within an hour
or so.
However, note that the authors used a big
honking machine to compute this scene.
And remember, this paper is not about optimization,
but it is about making the impossible possible.
And it is doing all that, swiftly.
Huge congratulations to the authors!
What
a
time
to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!